in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Juan
and Stephanie are with us hey guys how
are ya
we're doing good we're so glad to be
here we love you
we're honored your hair thank you for
coming very cool where do you live
Fort Worth Texas very cool and you're
here to do a debt free scream that's
right love that how much have you paid
off 40,000
alright good for you and how long did
that take 44 months good for you and
your range of income during that time I
kind of buried it was started off at
around 70,000 and then we went down to
one income 30,000 mm-hmm and now
currently it's 95 95 yes okay made home
for a little bit when we had our
daughter and Malia and then now I've
been back in the workforce for a couple
of years so yeah absolutely how what do
y'all do for a living I'm I work for the
Fort Worth Police Department as a
dispatcher mm-hmm and I'm an accountant
okay very cool good for you guys yeah so
what kind of debt was the 40,000
consisted of student loans my student
okay yeah two car payments medical bills
and seven seven credit cards Dave you
guys were normal yes you had everything
every kind of debt yeah you just like
normal Americans yeah so 44 months ago
what happened what got you on this track
yes well you know in January of 2012 we
just came to a decision that we were
tired of living paycheck to paycheck
just like many families we were making a
decent income for a dual income couple
with no kids the Dinks I am I think is
what the term is and but we were always
broke and we were using credit cards and
we were just in a hot mess you know
mm-hmm and so we decided in January to
stop using the credit cards and but we
really didn't have a plan we hadn't
heard of you or the program yet and then
just two months after that we found
we were pregnant with Emilia and so a
couple of our friends had told us about
the class and so September of 2012 we
took the class and it changed our lives
Dave we just we just got gizelle intense
as you say and now we're coordinating
and we're on our fifth class Wow yeah
we're doing the FPU flex for the first
time very cool Financial Peace
University coordinators now look at that
yeah look at you now you got a story to
tell for sure
Wow very cool very cool
so 44 months that's a while maybe you
belong in through this yeah how did you
stick with it oh well you were
coordinating classes you have a choice
right yeah I think that was so one of
the biggest things is that we found
balance Dave we were gizelle intense
Juan picked up so much overtime which
I'm very grateful for I dog sat on the
side we had a couple of garage sales to
help get us out but overall we just when
one of us would get weak you know or
want to go make a purchase and impulse
buy or whatever the other person would
kind of keep that person in check and
just kind of talk each other through and
coordinating the class honestly part of
the reason that we do it is to stay
ghazal intense and to get you know when
you're in that class with those people
and they're in in the in the same class
same situation it motivates you right to
be with the same kind of people so
that's what we did
there's nothing like teaching something
to make you really learn it to you on
track I think that's what FPU did has
done first coordinating is to keep us on
track it's huge accountability yeah
excellent excellent job way to go you
guys I'm so proud of ya you gotta feel
great how's it feel
Dave freeing and we're looking to the
future we're looking to the future you
know a couple years ago we just didn't
know we were kind of stuck we didn't
know but now it's like we have options
and we can accomplish those or we can
you know look towards those options look
toward us towards those goals
and actually you know go get him yeah
yeah very
cool well way to go you guys very very
very good what was the hardest part of
this for y'all
well I mean we for us you know
communicating and you know sticking with
the budget and everything like that but
the the hardest part I believe was you
know the accountability you know keeping
each other accountable and really
staying because they'll intense you know
and picking up overtime as much as I
didn't want to I knew that those 60 hour
weeks you know we're gonna Bennett were
for the future we're you know it's gonna
pay off eventually we're like no one
else so later make a living is like no
one else yes and I see you know all the
people around us friends and family who
are living like we used to live where
you know they have new cars I'm drunk
we're both driving ten-year-old vehicles
right now they're they work and they
look they look decent but they're old
you know they're getting up there but
for us it's their paid off so that's the
important thing but I think for me the
hardest thing was just to see everyone
around you not doing what you're doing
and kind of looking at you weird you
know like why are you doing this you
know when you have a good income
absolutely
oh well done good job we're gonna give
you a copy of Chris Hogan's book retire
inspired because that's the next step
that's we want you to continue the
journey this is the next chapter in your
book and your story and so way to go you
guys very well done
alright so it has Amelia have been
practicing with you oh the car she's
louder than we are okay very cool and
how old is she
so before in December okay very cool
good good deal all right Juan and
Stephanie and Amelia $40,000 paid off in
44 months making 70 then 30 than 95
counted down let's hear a debt free
scream 3
the best she has been practicing well
done you guys love it love it love it oh
that's awesome that's as good as it gets
right there very proud of you guys
excellent job hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income a $500,000 in the
common